also wir kommen aus dem gesundheitsmarkt
waren schon vor corona gesundheitspaket
ich in der prävention haben mit der
pandemie mit ärzten uns verständigt und
gesehen dass die arbeitnehmer in den
arbeitsplätzen
weiter tätig sein müssen und sie nicht
in locker umgehen können und sie
brauchen schutzmechanismen und der
unsere wirtschaft unsere betriebe müssen
weiter existieren auch in der pandemie
und haben dann dort testungen eingeführt
damals 1 gs gab es keine impfung und wir
haben dann begonnen mit der impfung also
mit dem verfügbarkeit des impfstoffs
auch impfungen in unternehmen anzubieten
und wir sehen also dass die beiden
seiten sowohl testen wie impfen dass das
bus begleiten wird jetzt durch herbst
winter ich bin offen ja ja ja der
meinung 3g ist das credo und nicht 2 g
weil ganz einfach die geimpfte sich auch
ansteckend für den virus weitergeben
warum sollten wir jetzt vor weihnachten
in zwei verschiedenen lagern verbringen
das halte ich für keine gute idee ganz
im gegenteil wir sollten uns auf die
machbarkeit von tess konzepten und das
impfen weiter verstärken aber das muss
man so sehen wir dass er digital
passieren indem wir den status aufnehmen
und dann gezielte angebote machen
personalisierte für jeden der auch
aufklärung braucht das dann dort ein
angebot entsteht und damit leben wir in
der neuen normalität so lange wie es
erforderlich ist und machen uns nicht
den ganzen tag gedanken wann ist es
vorbei wenn es vorbei wir leben damit
und versuchen gemeinsam dadurch die
pandemie zu kommen
ich glaube dass wir
uns mit zweig in einer falschen
sicherheit wiegen im übrigen weil wir
gleichzeitig menschen ausschließen die
angst haben und den menschen nicht die
ängste nehmen wir brauchen vielmehr
wieder eine debatte um die frage sollten
wir die bürger tests wieder einführen
sollten wir wieder kostenfreie bürger
tests in unserem land ermöglichen und
nicht unsere kraftanstrengungen darauf
verschwenden ob wir jetzt von 3g auf
zwei gegeben sondern mir geht es um die
selbstbestimmtheit jedes einzelnen und
die können wir mit einer solchen
umfassenden test strategie und einer
guten impfstrategie einer verstärkung
der impfstrategie gewährleisten und mich
ärgert dabei auch die rolle von ihren
sparen massiv der hier tatsächlich
gerade wenn es um die
auffrischungsimpfungen geht für die
risikogruppen aus meiner sicht zu
zögerlich gehandelt hat und auch im
umgang mit der stiko an durchaus hätte
weiter sein können als er im augenblick
ist und wir damit wieder zeit verloren
habe vielleicht sogar zurücktreten
müssen nach der masken affäre und
anderen skandalen das fragen sich viele
bürger die frage ist da war der job
gemacht als gesundheitsminister ich habe
mir die frage damals auch gestellt und
das ist natürlich eine situation wo du
sagst das lernst du alles ab was da
passiert das findet findest du alles
nicht richtig dass dafür kannst du jede
menge haltungsnoten geben kommt immer
zum ergebnis falsch falsch falsch aber
in einer krise den gesundheitsminister
vor die tür zu setzen ist eine andere
frage die man diskutieren müsste können
wir hier diskutieren weil du brauchst
ihn um das zu managen um durch diese
krise durch zu kommen und das war für
mich die abwägungsfrage obmann rücktritt
richtig oder falsch findet und für mich
war zu dem punkt ich hab das alles
abgelehnt aber ich hab gesagt jetzt neun
minister ins amt zu holen in einer
krisen phase wo es sicherheit
beständigkeit im land braucht wäre der
völlig falschen weg für mich gewesen es
hat ja fast eine gewisse tragik für ihn
eigentlich jemand der zwischenzeitlich
kannst ohne ambitionen hatte und dann
kam diese pandemie und hat ihm das
letztlich verhagelt obwohl ihr insgesamt
glaube ich einen so schlechten job
ähnlicher weise auch nicht gemacht und
auch heute noch da bin ich ganz ganz
sicher ich war zum beispiel letztes jahr
der anfang des jahres bei einem
schnelltest hersteller bei einem der
größten deutschlands und dann hat die
entspannender gerade verkündet dass wir
jetzt alles schnell jetzt haben da habe
ich gefragt hat er denn schon bestellt
nein und auch in den kreuz die er mit
anderen hätte hätte ich entspannen auch
noch nirgendwo bestellt und dann habe
ich gedacht weil das sagt man ja immer
das gefühl selber denken so ok der
unternehmer will seine schnelltest
verkaufen vielleicht sind seine einfach
nicht gut was war kam ja am ende raus
das war noch gar keine bestellt und das
muss ich sagen es war unternehmerisch
gesehen wie die korona krise gemanagt
wurde ich meine von dem schnelltest
hersteller bei dem ich war so verkaufte
die meisten schneite es auch hin in die
schweiz und nach england und dass wir
nicht früher aber es stimmt hier sitzt
ja auch ein schnelltest hersteller neben
ja da können wir direkt mal fragen wie
lief das denn mit den schnelltest und
der regierung ab war es gut geendet na
ja also ich glaube die frage ist sich
die verfügbarkeit der tests sondern die
frage ist wie kommen die tests werden
sie angewendet und wofür diese stadt und
wir haben uns sehr schwer getan
schnelltest die da sind die 1 wie wir
festgestellt haben jeder im grunde
machen kann mit etwas anleitung dass wir
monate gebraucht haben bis wir das
zugelassen haben dass also nicht eine
medizinische fachkraft erforderlich ist
um ein schnelltest zum hat die
bundesregierung in früh genug überhaupt
die städte jetzt bestellt bei
schnelltest herstellern wie ihn na ja
das kann ich jetzt gar nicht im detail
sagen weil ich nicht weiß wann die
bundesregierung angefangen hat zu suchen
aber man hätte sicherlich sehr
frühzeitig schon am ursprung tests
finden können auch heute wird es so sein
dass ab wann werden die verfügbar
gewesen ich denke so mitte letzten
jahres werden sie mit sicherheit 20 mal
die unternehmertochter politik ist
okay aber er hat ein unternehmen gründet
dann erwarten sofern es sie ist eher ein
unternehmer insofern hast du ein ganz
anderer spirit als politik in der
politik das war sie aus eigener
erfahrung mahlen die mühlen anders und
wenn ihr gespannt wie ich gesagt hat
haben wir diese schnelltest und
irgendein beamter die musik hamburg
kriegen wir dann ist es noch nicht
gegeben dass es wirklich so ist er malen
viele räder und ein minister kann nicht
alles überwachen da gibt es auch
widerstände die man überwinden muss und
da gibt es unwägbarkeiten das ist keine
rausreden in vor dem hintergrund meine
ich dass sie entspannt ein relativ guten
job gemacht hat auch für ihn war alles
neu diese pandemie hat keiner jemals
vorher gehabt weltweit nicht und
insofern war das 1 1 1 1 fahren auf
sicht und auch wenn er sich heute gerade
erklärt hat und gesagt hat er will nicht
parteivorsitzender noch nicht werden
glaube ich der politische weg von jens
spahn ist noch lange nicht vorbei
spannender frau aber die frage ist ja
sollten wir wieder kostenlose bürger
tests an zu glauben das wird ja kommen
so oder so fordernd
und da sollen die kostenlosen tests
wieder komme ich hatte es halte es für
wichtig halte das auch deshalb für
wichtig weil es auch denen die im
übrigen geimpft sind und denen die
chinesen sind eine sicherheit gibt und
wir müssen doch wieder sicherheit
schaffen um diese pandemie wieder ein
bisschen mehr in den griff zu bekommen
und 2 g wiegt eben viele in falscher
sicherheit ob wir hier fünf mal
die frage ist ja wir kommen diese
kostenlosen test beim bürger an und
nochmal tests zelte zur schloss ist ja
nie was muss und her gehen das sowieso
genau aber letztendlich für den nutzer
kostenfrei
diese tests sind im winter nicht draußen
geeignet also die müssen es
raumtemperatur haben damit fragen schon
mal zählte aus und es ist auch deutlich
weniger nachfrage war ja 25 prozent oder
75 prozent ja geimpft sind unser credo
ist dass die testung bei den
arbeitgebern stattfinden ist die
arbeitgeber die mitarbeiter testen
zertifikate ausstellen und wenn ich in
eine speicherung laufen sondern dass mit
diesen validierten zertifikat cw
anbindung der mitarbeiter auch
entsprechend zum friseur ins kino oder
auch private veranstaltungen nutzen kann
also nicht wieder zählt landschaften auf
die straße aber ihr credo ist eine
pflicht für die arbeitgeber rings
richtig verstehe auf jeden fall ja das
war aber das gilt auch für den
arbeitnehmer als pflicht nämlich auch
seinen status dem arbeitgeber
mitzuteilen denn nur dann kann der
arbeitgeber seiner fürsorgepflicht
gerecht werden nämlich ein spezifisches
personalisiertes angebot zu machen
denken wir doch mal dran war nicht im
zertifikate aus laufen ja aber das hilft
auch alles nur wenn man es auch
kontrolliert wenn die schönste test
hilft ja nix wenn sich kontrolliert wird
wir sehen doch so viele wirte so viele
kneipen so viele restaurants und sowohl
es mittlerweile sehr laissez-faire mäßig
gehandhabt wird und ich bin auch wir
brauchen eine grenzen übergreifende
regelung also es kann nicht sein dass in
bremen auch wenn die institute der
geringer sind eine andere regelung als
bayern in bayern läuft sondern das muss
bundesweit zu sein ist eine gute idee
wenn sie sagen das was am arbeitsplatz
getestet wird das muss auch so dann
würdest du dich sagen wir mal drei mal
die woche testen lassen gerne
möchte 13 findest du das gut also ich
gebe zu dass ich mich schon wie zu lange
nicht habe testen lassen und so
wahrscheinlich dringend mal wieder tun
sollte
ich bin geimpft menschen die sich
begeben haha man lacht aber das kommt
also genau ist jetzt geht es wiederum
dass man sagt wir nehmen hier gerade so
so so drüber hinweg wir reden das eine
ist die schule dass der staat für
verantwortlich wir reden hier teilweise
über über staatliches versagen und ja zu
sagen wir den arbeitgebern in diesem
land ihr habt die kosten und die
infrastrukturen das alles zu
organisieren und lagern das einmal
komplett aus also staatliches versagen
wird komplett auf die unternehmen
ausgelagert kammer machen
aber sollten wir darüber sprechen ob das
wirklich der richtige weg ist mein mann
fragezeichen waren ja moment also für
die arbeitgeber ist es wichtig dass der
betrieb sicher läuft ja gerade jetzt
herbst und winter weihnachtsgeschäft die
wanne absicherung des geschäftsbetriebs
also ist der arbeitgeber hat ein
eigeninteresse der arbeitnehmer möchte
auch geschützt habe aber es platzt
unterkommen alle leute hin wir haben
dort ein kompetentes umfeld wenn wir das
alles versuchen mit neuen strukturen die
der staat entwickelt und dann aufbaut
dann ist die frage funktioniert das
besser
also der staat müsste ja keine neuen
strukturen aufbauen er kann ja auf
bewährtes zurückgreifen naja so eine
apotheke hat ja nur bis zum 6 geöffnet
wie soll denn dann jemand abends sich in
afrika